welcome back 6 24 they traveled all the
way from australia just for residency in
the entertainment capital of the world
they've been a staple here for more than
a decade and it's a new show it is a new
venue our favorite aussies human nature
thank you pleasure good day good day
good night so you guys have been in
australia recently so you said the
accent's thick it's back yeah we have
yeah we've got a top up yeah we've been
there i did a massive tour for about
three and a half months and we're back
ready to do our a new show starting this
week it's very exciting and the show is
where it's at the south point
at the south point yes we're at
southwest school back to the sound of
motown uh this motown's what brought us
to vegas almost 13 years ago so it's
great to get back there and just um the
south point's awesome the the showroom's
fantastic and we're planning to be the
kings of south point so that's our
that's our effort
i was at the south point over the
weekend you guys are all over plastered
all over the wall so i think you've
already taken the crown you're already
the kings you guys have toured with some
incredible artists i mean michael
jackson celine dion but you are the
headliners here this is all about you
what can folks expect from the show
it's exciting you know i mean it's
called back to the sound of motown so
they expect a lot of motown songs a lot
of you know people's favorites a couple
of maybe a couple of our hits from
australia you know introduce them to
some of our music but um it's just a fun
show you know we we love having fun with
the audience and getting them involved
as well so expect to come and sing along
and and dance as well we are we love the
crowd getting into it so now uh there's
a premium on these tickets because
there's only a handful left for the show
that's coming up that starts on thursday
yes we got four shows this week and then
but we'll be back each month so we're
back september october and november so
people can go on to the south point
website check out dates and yeah if you
can't get tickets for this weekend come
and see us uh yeah when we're here in
the next couple of months such a fun
show
you know and i don't want to delay
because obviously you guys have
incredible voices it's what people come
to see the harmony just the incredible
i guess artistry particularly
particularly at 6am yeah
yes
your throat well let me get out of the
way because we'd love to hear what you
do
a little bit of smokey robinson for you
this morning
too
[Music]
[Music]
so take a good look at my face
you see my smile
looks out of place
if you look closer it's easy to trace
the tracks of my tears
[Applause]
just a small snippet of what you can
expect at the south point human nature
thank you again for being here good
morning